en eeuu la justicia electoral depende de
cada estado y es por ello que en georgia
exigen que más del 50% de los votos sea
necesario para proclamarse senador y por
ello va a repetir las elecciones del
próximo día 5 de enero es importante lo
que pase en georgia porque de aquí salen
dos senadores que van a cambiar el color
político del senado en caso de que
salgan demócratas o mantener el poder
que ha tenido hasta entonces los
republicanos en la cámara alta
estaríamos delante de una cuestión
importantísima para la gobernabilidad
del futuro presidente joe biden y eso lo
saben todos los actores políticos por
ejemplo mike pence el actual
vicepresidente ha estado ciento campaña
en georgia y hoy son muchos los
simpatizantes de trump que están aquí
delante del capitolio en atlanta
pidiendo una elección justa todavía no
aceptan los resultados de noviembre
porque donald trump precisamente ha
estado reclamando que no son votos
legales muchos de los que determinaron
que ganará joe biden por tanto georgia
es el estado donde ahora nos estamos
fijando para saber el futuro de eeuu
[Aplausos]